See today is motivated by perpetuating
a system of elite capture
built on corruption
and increasing government dependence
through its national democratic revolution
and while clearly deepening relations with the Chinese
Communist Party and Putin's Russia.
As a black man,
I carry the knowledge of my own country's
historical burden of inequality.
And as a conservative black man,
I understand that hard work,
perseverance
and getting a shot pays off.
That is clearly not the case
in South Africa's ruling party
where nearly 30 years into ANC rule,
the South African people are more dependent
and than ever
on a state that fails to consistently
provide even the most basic services
and provides bad policy.
Take the example of black economic empowerment,
a policy intended to support
historically disadvantaged black citizens
by providing increased access to the economy,
but one that is repeatedly
been undermined by corruption and nepotism
from the ANC elites
who have manipulated the scheme for personal gain
at the expense of the broader black populace.
The ANC elite are focused on increasing
dependence on the state in order to exert control.
Recently, it was publicly stated
that there are now 18 million South Africans
receiving state grants
compared to just 2.5 million in 1999.
Much of this going to provide
basic needs
at the failure of state to generate
meaningful and sustained employment
that can only come with a healthy
growing private sector.
Another disastrous policy is the ANC's land reform
effort to enforce expropriation without compensation
and destroy South Africa's constitutionally protected
private property rights.
The ANC claims that land reform and E. W.
C. Are widely popular,
but their own surveys show that only 2% of black South
Africans identify land reform as a serious
unresolved problem,
while 80% prioritize economic
growth and more jobs over land expropriation.
Despite this,
the ANC is currently pushing
the Expropriation Bill and Land Court Bill
through Parliament
to reward themselves for a job poorly done.
There is no country in the world
that has remained democratic after removing its
population's private property rights.
And I remain concerned about the ANC's democratic drift
away from constitutional rule,
especially in light of the election.